I want to take a moment to acknowledge
someone we lost too recently to include
in our film tribute he wasn't a
filmmaker but he was definitely a member
of our film community now he clobbered
some of us with a great big stick and
sometimes he touched us with a velvet
glove I'm talking about Gene Siskel
a critic but more important he really
loved movies so Jean wherever you are
honey he is to you
now to present the award for
cinematography of vision that any
cinematographer is happy to find on the
other end of his camera she was
nominated for an Oscar for her
heart-stopping performance in Pulp
Fiction ladies and gentlemen please
welcome the sumptuous uma Thurman
good evening art meets science and
cinematography our cinematographers
control the emotional art of motion
pictures by bending light arresting
colors and evoking passions and
recognized for their contributions the
nominees are
Konrad L Hall for a civil action Remi at
a Pharisee for Elizabeth
Janusz Kaminski for Saving Private Ryan
Richard great Rex for Shakespeare in
Love and John told for The Thin Red Line
and the Oscar goes to and the Oscar goes
to
Janusz Kaminski for Saving Private Ryan
Janusz Kaminski was previously nominated
for filming Amistad and won the award
for Schindler's List
hmm thank you very much behind the
handheld camera there people and that's
midge Durbin Sheamus and Chris Harper
and I want to thank him very much I want
to thank the producers of course the
actors Stephen the great collaborator my
sugar bear Holly
ladies and gentlemen three-time Oscar
winner mr. Jack Nicholson
thank you for that